first of all let's just start from the
beginning of the creation
of unzipped what was that one thing
where you were like
yes this needs to happen okay should i
answer that i we were just talking one
day it was like a couple months into the
lockdown
last year and we were catching up on the
phone
just updating each other on all of the
things in life
because we would you know we go these
periods without connecting so we got a
lot to say
and it kind of occurred to me that these
tangents the animals that i
go on when we're talking to each other
could be a really fun conversation to
share
with other people you know our dynamic
on a personal level has evolved so much
since the show 90210 where people got to
know us
as this kind of like dynamic frenemy duo
and i thought it would be a nice
opportunity and a great platform to
reintroduce ourselves
to people all these years later as
ourselves
um speaking about the things that we're
really passionate about so it's been a
lot of fun
and a labor of love for sure
to to put it all together and so when
you guys do have the conversations
let's say about the five year feud when
you are talking about that
how new are these conversations for you
guys so meaning
when did you first have the conversation
compared to when we all heard this
conversation
when you all heard the conversation
really
yeah absolutely we literally did not
so shanae and i were little water signs
she's a scorpio i'm a cancer we're very
much
energy people so i could feel her vibe
she can feel my vibe there was
not the coldest vibe for like five years
on that as you know
and then the vibe changed and we just
kind of let silt milk be spilt milk
water
under the bridge and we just picked up
our life after
we lived this you know i went to her
wedding we
she had a baby we i i come to out to see
her
at the house and you know we just have
dinner parties and just as if nothing
had ever happened
but we never it was just the thing we
never spoke about
and so then i was in an interview at one
point and wendy williams like
you gotta love her she's so salacious
and she's like you need to tell me what
went down with that cheney
girl and i was like okay i was like well
i want to choke her out
half the time i was on the show and so
then that became this thing that like
oh you know it really was a feud and
there really was a thing
so right before the night before we
recorded the podcast was the first time
we even broached the topic
of what went down and then we just were
like you know what
might as well have it be organic roll
camera roll tape like
let's go i want to get i want to get
your take on this because i
was what jason priestley described to me
as being on the cycle of the original
90210 which is
i started high school the year they
started high school i graduated high
school
the year the show graduated high school
so i my life was the perfect 90210 run
and so i remember that time very clearly
and as much as i loved the
show the one thing that almost at times
overshadowed the show was the drama
behind the scenes
how everybody was out to get shannon
doherty and there was all this
infighting and all of this stuff
and then your show started and people
were almost
expecting that to the point of where it
was encouraged
because it wasn't 90210 without
that yes you nailed it i mean
i i definitely think that in
particular and i think we broached this
in that initial episode you know i was
taking on
shannon's role so to speak um in the
series i was one of the brother-sister
duo that moved from the small town to
west beverly high and whatever and um i
was also
fresh out of canada i was super green
nobody had ever seen me in america
before so i was kind of a blank slate
for the media to make
whatever they wanted out of me and
they just pitch and hold me right into
that same box and
um you know tarnish me with that brush
that they turn to shannon with because
i mean i've met shannon i look up to
shannon so much she
she was the warmest out of everybody
that i've met on the original series
when she came and
guest starred on our show i absolutely
adored her and she is such a
professional so
um you know people just maybe jason
priestley who was a director on the show
and he was he was super warm and fuzzy i
loved
jason so much he still can't pronounce
my name correctly so i do hold that
against him but i'll let it go because
he's jason
priestley but
you know i i think they put us into that
category it was always like
you know which girls were kind of
ganging up against the other girl
and you know something that we did bring
up on the show is that even when the
stories
are being written about you and people
that you know in real life
when they're circulated enough and
enough people are talking about them
it's really hard to maintain a
clear and realistic perspective even
when you know the people
because you're being fed this
information on a daily basis you know
crazy stories would come out about me
and i could feel the energy shift
walking onto set even though these
people knew me none of the things that
were written
some of the things that were written
were true but some of the things weren't
and and they didn't witness any of the
things of the stories that they were
reading in the tabloids but you could
feel
people looking at me differently
treating me differently
and i think that really played into the
real life drama that ended up unfolding
behind the scenes
what was the mo what was that what was
it uh uh something that was untrue
that hurt the most um the the fact that
i was like a drug addict
like i was doing coke all the time um
oh yeah i got that one too i still
wonder how fun that cocaine was
yeah i've never done drugs um
like that i've never tried cocaine in my
life like i am
quite a goody two-shoes when it comes
that kind of stuff i have a long line of
addiction in my family so i always knew
to stay away from that kind of thing
and i think as a young woman especially
growing up in this hollywood scene where
you really do
it's a very adult world you have
everything handed to you
if you want it and i'm proud of myself
for maintaining a level head and not
going down any of these dark paths
that were very available to me so i felt
like that really stripped a lot away
from
my character and the choices that i made
as an 18 year old
famous 18 year old living in hollywood
all by herself i could have done
whatever i wanted
you know and and i maintained a pretty
grounded level head so
that one really stung a lot but analyn
let me ask you this because
it seems to me that it's a very
difficult situation to be in when you
are that young that famous where so much
is written about you that's hurtful
and untrue where you can't defend
everything you can't stand up and say
this isn't true this isn't true this
isn't true there's a certain amount of
it that you just have to eat
there is there's a certain amount of it
you know something early on for me
i i've been slammed with things my
since well before tabloids um one being
that everybody thinks i'm anorexic at
all times
throughout my whole life and i couldn't
eat more food in the whole world i
literally will eat my lunch and yours
too but
at a certain point and especially coming
into
the hollywood scene um one of the things
there there was a quote that i read when
i was about
18 or 19 right before i did nip talk and
it was something
along the lines of don't believe
anything good that people say about you
because if you believe the good
then you have to believe the bad just
know who you are
and and i think that really sunk in
for me because during this whole period
and i'm not really someone who
read tabloids i'm a very weird little
person who does strange things and not
typical
pop culture pop culture things um but
that
definitely helped me to to keep myself
out of it to a certain extent i i still
was met with
you know the the rumors and the stuff
and when it did get to me it was
it it was more laughable because i
maybe i'm just really super defensive
but i i would laugh at the stuff that i
would hear
but but shanae was really attacked
especially the first year
um can i ask you about the did the
disassociative identity disorder
diagnosis and you being so open about it
can you explain
quickly what it is to people that may
not know what that is and how you deal
with it
absolutely so did disassociative
identity disorder
is not multiple personality disorder
which is what
people understood and uh rightfully so
thought it to be
it is not multiple personalities it is
fragmented identities of your
in literally fragmented parts of your
own self
so it often follows severe childhood
trauma or early life trauma
and in my experience what happened for
me was that it was unsafe
to know and to remember what was
happening to me as a child so
i just kept splitting my brain split
split split splits but it put all these
little traumas into little boxes so that
they would
not all come out at once and my memories
would go on to come back
when i was 31 years old so almost three
decades later
i remember what happened to me and then
i realized that
what felt like really strong mood shifts
where i would be in that mood for weeks
at a time or months at a time
was actually me being stuck in an
altered version of myself and not being
able to integrate those parts of me
and now i'm thankful to be a whole
person but it is
it is something that you know that
definitely played into
my work as an actress i think it
actually in this in one way it helped
because i was able to really dive into
the shoes of these characters but
sometimes i couldn't get out of them
yeah i'm so sorry to hear that well i
appreciate you
i appreciate you providing this platform
you et canada to to continue talking
about this issue because it means so
much to me to know that
sufferers and they've been reaching out
suppers of the idea been reaching out
and saying
i've been dealing with this for 70 years
it's the first time anyone's actually
made me feel
seen so i am so grateful for the
platform
and uh shanae i know you ran into this
interview um trying to
make nap time happen um which i i've
been there i understand it i get it it's
wild
and uh and how are you how are you doing
right now i mean you're you're you're
you're currently baking number two right
i am
yeah i'm like 27 weeks along with number
two
so it's an absolute mad house over here
um but you know we're we're managing
it's it's been difficult because we
haven't seen any of my family over in
canada
since february of last year we haven't
seen my
in-laws over in england since around
that same time
and we just got word today that you know
more flights are being
canceled and pushed back the
restrictions are tightening again so
it's been difficult to you know just do
all of the things that we do i work
full-time my husband works full-time and
then we're child
you know providing care for our child
full-time so i'm like
a little bit freaked out right now that
like baby number two is gonna get here
and we're still not gonna have any
familial support
but um it's been an incredible journey
we moved across the country
via car with a dog and a toddler mid
pandemic
and survive so we feel like a very very
strong
unit that's for sure incredible and
before i
i let you guys go um are there any sort
of
guests or guest stars to the podcast
that you would love to have
from the 90210 world i
am desperately trying to track down
shannon doherty i would absolutely love
to get her on the show to just talk
about the things we just spoke about
with you
you know she made such an amazing
impression on me when she did come and
guest on it because i was a big
fan of the original series and when she
was there i remember our showrunner
taking me into her trailer to meet her
and i was like
shaking i was so nervous and she just
opened up her arms gave me the warmest
hug
and i remember watching her on set in
awe when we were filming scenes together
just because of the way she commanded a
room her energy
is so strong and so
big and she knew her the ropes so well
and was so gracious with all of the crew
members i was like
that's it like that is a pro at work
right now and
it gave me a lot to look up to and i've
never connected with shannon
since all of those years ago so it would
just be an absolute pleasure to get to
talk to her
and we want russell brand even though he
wasn't on 90210
why not why he's amazing
this was incredible it was so wonderful
to finally see um both of you
again after so many years
congratulations on the podcast and uh
congratulations to both of you on on
everything
thank you so much for your time